>>Teacher: So, welcome to the Saugus
Ironworks National Historic site.
>>Narrator: It's a big
day for the fifth grade
at Ferryway School
just outside Boston.
>>Teacher: What's this
simple machine right here?
Wheel and axle, right.
>>Narrator: This field trip is the
highlight of a six-week project
that integrates science...
>>Teacher: This works like a lever
that presses the bellows closed,
blows the air into the furnace.
>>Narrator: ...math, art, English...
>>Teacher: So this is America's
first rolling and slitting mills.
>>Narrator: ...and history.
>>Teacher: There we go.
My metal's hot enough.
This is called a hearty.
What kind of simple machine is this?
>>Class: Wedge.
>>Teacher: Wedge.
>>Narrator: Students use
the latest technology tools
to study the country's
earliest innovations.
>>Teacher: And how's that?
A good-looking nail?
>>Class: Yeah.
>>Teacher: You guys
are too easy to please.
>>Narrator: To earn the right
to go on the field trip,
students spend weeks
accomplishing various tasks
to get their passport stamped.
>>Margie: All of those stamps
are based on our state standards,
from writing assignments
to design assignments.
And, as they finish the
assignment, the passport is stamped.
>>Narrator: All of the assignments
involve hands-on activities,
from creating an outfit
for a rock person...
>>Student: And it looks
like shiny metal.
>>Narrator: ...to studying
rocks and minerals,
which also involves
Internet research.
>>Student: Chemical composition
with an organized structure
of a natural inorganic origin.
>>Narrator: Technology specialist
Bob Simpson helped the team integrate
technology on the project.
>>Bob: Well, the teachers have
done all the really good research
and constructed the structure of how
the students are going to navigate
through that unit,
and ultimately what
that does is it empowers the
students to make decisions.
So, when they're researching rocks
and minerals, they get to pick
which Web site they want to go to
to select their rock or mineral.
>>So, go ahead and click
on your Internet browser.
>>Narrator: Students
also access the Web
to study the history
of the ironworks.
The Saugus unit site also
features a parent page
that is translated
into several languages.
>>Student: It's over here in the X.
>>Tom: We've had about 75 different
languages spoken in this community,
so you can imagine what that
brings to the table every day,
but this kind of cooperative work
environment, teachers and students,
supersedes that, and working with
the computer, working with a partner,
going on the field trip, those
things are the intangibles
that bring this whole project
to life and can reach kids
that you may never be able
to reach in other ways.
>>Student: This is a picture
and right here is a caption.
>>Bob: Your mission is to
write a description caption
for the pictures you took today.
>>Narrator: With digital cameras
the school received as part
of a technology grant, students
add their field-trip photos
to an ironworks wiki.
>>Bob: Let's get these
pictures into your laptops,
so connect your cable to your camera.
>>Margie: I've seen lots
of intrinsic learning.
I think the kids own
what they've learned.
They're very proud of their work.
They can talk about their
work, and they share much more.
>>Student: Do you like
the other one too?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Margie: They're learning
through the technology definitely
and with the technology, and they're
able to sort of publish themselves
at a level that we haven't
been able to do before.
>>Student: Wait.
What's that?
>>Student: I don't know.
I think you took that.
>>Narrator: The integration
of various subjects
in one project also seems to work.
>>Anxhela: If you're in different
classes, you sometimes forget,
because your mind's on one class,
and then you have to be focused
on another class, but when it's
all together you can just focus
on one thing, because
it's all the same.
>>Margie: The circumference of the
circle, so when you measure around...
>>Narrator: The most exciting
hands-on activity is a competition
to build the most efficient
Styrofoam water wheel.
>>Teacher: Sixteenth of an inch.
I mean, we're talking
maybe two millimeters.
>>Narrator: As part of a team of more
than a dozen teachers and mentors
on the project, Earl Fitzpatrick
runs the school's tech lab.
>>Earl: The technology
education lab is a place
where the students can
come into the room,
actually physically
construct a project.
It gives them ownership.
They built it.
They'll test it, and in this
case we'll have not only learned
about the water wheel, but they
learned about all the tools
and machines that it takes to
produce a working prototype,
the steps in the design process
and, whether it succeeds or fails,
they can come back and rebuild
it to make it a success.
>>Class: [chants]
>>Earl: And they can actually
test it to see if it works
and compare their work
against other students.
It's almost self-grading.
>>Two hundred and fifty grams
plus one thousand grams.
>>There's no need to
grade the project.
I mean, you put it on the test
stand and see how much it lifts,
and the kids can know,
"Hey, I made a good effort
and my water wheel is efficient.
I've achieved the goal."
>>Narrator: Whether they finish first
or last, the teams are encouraged
to learn from their efforts.
>>Andy: Looking at where
the water's spilling out
and how the wheel is operating right
now, what might you change about it?
>>Student: Bigger cups.
>>Andy: Some bigger cups.
So why would you add bigger cups?
>>Student: So there
could be more water.
>>Narrator: Graduate
engineering student Andy Mueller
from nearby Tufts University guides
them through the redesign process.
>>Andy: This is exactly
what engineers do.
You don't know how something is
going to operate until you build it
and test it until failure.
Now we know that there's a lot of
water spilling out the side of this.
You might want to add...
>>You don't really know
what you want to do.
If you can see someone that's excited
about anything, it helps the kids
out to maybe say, "Well, if he is
that excited about engineering,"
then get the kids excited about it,
and maybe they'll want
to go into engineering.
>>Teacher: Their water
wheels seem far more advanced
than the first year.
Where did that come from?
How did that...
>>Narrator: Redesign is also part
of the process for the teaching team
that created the ironworks
project in 2002.
>>Earl: We had time in the shop.
Then the two fifth-grade science
teachers were very flexible, I mean,
to the point where we
were on the phone up-
and downstairs shuttling students up
and down so that they could re-glue.
They had time to decorate.
They had time to make
last-minute adjustments,
things that we didn't have before.
It adds a component.
That technology component
makes a big difference.
>>Narrator: Buoyed by the
success of the ironworks project,
the team tackled another project.
>>Paul: So, today we're going
to look at pictures of animals
and we're going to make predictions
about the biomes that they live
in based on all the work
that you've done to date.
>>Narrator: As part of a
second-year HP technology grant,
the fifth-grade team
mentored fourth-grade teachers
in developing the biome unit.
>>Paul: And then you
ask the question,
so it's three different ways.
>>Teacher: You're going to
bring me at least up to here?
>>Paul: Yeah.
>>Narrator: The project
started with a Web quest,
which led to students designing
PowerPoint presentations
of a particular biome.
>>Paul: All right.
Take a look.
Slide looks really good.
Climagraph looks good.
>>Narrator: Information
for the PowerPoint presentations
came from Internet research.
>>Sara: Who can tell
me what a herbivore is?
>>It's just been a totally
wonderful experience.
They actually are looking
forward to something for a change.
I think it's just hands-on
and they don't have to listen
to my voice droning on and on
and they're discovering
things on their own.
It's just amazing, some of
the questions that have come
up from their own discoveries instead
of me feeding all the
information to them.
I think that's the biggest piece.
>>Teacher: It's related to the
wolverines, minx and weasels.
>>Narrator: At the end of the
unit, they were challenged
to justify why a certain animal
might live in a given biome.
>>Paul: So, using your remotes,
make sure that you select a biome.
>>Narrator: And their answers
were tabulated instantly
with a student-response system.
>>Student: I chose the
temperature of the deciduous forest,
because there's lots
of rodents there.
>>Paul: We wanted to keep
that idea of inquiry-based,
so it enabled the students to kind
of start that type of learning,
which is a stretch for a lot of kids,
because they are used
to: Open the book.
Read the chapter.
Answer the questions.
This is different.
It's not necessarily a
matter of right or wrong.
If you can justify it, if
you can support your answer,
then it's a valuable answer, and the
students respond to that quite well
and they remember what it
is that they're learning.
>>Who chose the rainforest?
>>Student: I chose the rainforest
because there are a lot of insects,
and it eats insects, so it's
one of its food sources.
>>Narrator: The biome and ironworks
projects inspired both teachers
and students, and their
test scores rose well
above other fifth-graders
in the district.
>>Student: I took that picture.
>>Earl: There's a lot of life
lessons to be learned by physical,
hands-on projects, whether
it be a science experiment,
a tech-ed experiment.
They learn leadership roles.
They learn how to get
along, how to cooperate,
and it's good for everyone.
>>Teacher: Here we go.
>>Class: [chants]
>>Earl: Often you don't
have the chance to show kids
that education is real, that there
is value to it, that it's out there,
and they get a chance to
put that all together.
Once in a while, the magic happens,
and it has happened the last couple
of days and it's happened the
last five years we've been doing
this project.
>>Class: [cheers]
>>Teacher: You're on the lift.
>>Narrator: For more
information on What Works
in Public Education,
go to edutopia.org.